this video is sponsored by Legal Zoom
more about Legal Zoom at the end of the
video hey wisecrack Jared again this is
me at the midnight screening of The Dark
Knight Rises back in 2012 needless to
say I was out of my mind excited but
despite my Dark Knight infatuation I
couldn't help but be disappointed The
Dark Knight Rises is not necessarily a
bad movie not stops legend it just hails
in comparison to its predecessor but as
with anything graced with the name Nolan
and by that I mean this one this film
has a lot of intellectual ambition
unfortunately not all of it pans out so
let's dive in to see what works and what
doesn't
welcome to a special wisecrack edition
on the Dark Knight Rises what went wrong
and of course spoilers ahead a lot of my
disappointment with the Dark Knight
Rises stems from its smart set up but
questionable execution so let's start
with one of its smartest elements the
very unexpected influence of Charles
Dickens A Tale of Two Cities
The Dark Knight Rises replicates most of
the books major themes including social
inequality resurrection and doubling the
most obvious Ematic parallel with the
Tale of Two Cities is social inequality
next and go breakfast ends the rest of
us huh the book setting the French
Revolution depicts a decadent
aristocracy and their abuse of the poor
likewise the film portrays a similar
class conflict through Bane's false
revolution now we came here about to
stun guru but as liberators return to
control this city to the people the
third book in the novel is called track
of a storm and Catwoman says
then there's the theme of Resurrection
in A Tale of Two Cities
Dickens frequently uses the phrase
recalled to life to signify that his
characters are metaphorically brought
back from the dead one of the main
characters is metaphorically brought
back to life when he sees his daughter
after 18 years in the Bastille or in his
words buried alive
similarly Bruce Wayne is metaphorically
recalled to life when Catwoman steals
his fingerprints forcing him to leave
Wayne Manor after eight years of
self-imposed isolation I care for no man
on earth and no man cares for me another
character named carton is resurrected
when he sacrifices himself for another
character take my coat hi thus giving
meaning to his aimless life this arc is
reflected in Catwoman I'll open that
tunnel that I'm gone as for you than
that who overcomes her selfishness and
saves Batman this can also be likened to
officer Foley who sacrificed his life to
save Gotham after being complacent with
the takeover guy trying the city we've
all got to keep our heads down sleek
carton even quotes the story of Lazarus
Lazarus of course being the guy Christ
resurrected in the Bible
Bruce is metaphorically resurrected when
he rebuilds his strength and climbs out
of the Lazarus Pit darnay the guy carton
saved is given a second chance at life
when he spared from execution and Bruce
is again metaphorically resurrected when
we find out at the end that he is in
fact not dead and has given a second
chance to live a more rewarding life
even the title The Dark Knight Rises
invokes a phoenix rising from the ashes
the poster for the film swaps out a
Phoenix for the bat symbol and chapter
23 of A Tale of Two Cities is called
fire rises after the time yeah the fire
rises oh yeah and both texts feature a
capitalist named Stryver there's no
mistake mr. Stryver
at Batman's funeral Gordon even reads
this line about carton sacrifice and
moral resurrection straight from the end
of A Tale of Two Cities it's a far far
better painter I do it is a far far
better thing that I do and I specify the
finally there's the theme of doubling
you've probably heard the opening lines
it was the best of times it was the
worst of time this contrasting between
pairs between best of times and worst of
times between age of wisdom and
foolishness
between epoch of belief and incredulity
happens throughout the whole book there
are two manase two cities London and
Paris
Darnay has two trials and Darnay and
carton look the exact same in the Dark
Knight Rises there's two cities Gotham
and Bane's underground Batman and Bane
to League of Shadows alums who deal with
unbearable pain estimating the spectra
enemy the mesh hose the payment Bay one
board and privilege another born in Hell
Blake and Batman are both orphans with
anger issues a lot of people know it
feels like do they be angry in your
bones and a constant reminder of the
division between body and soul yeah but
not of your body
so what we've got here is probably the
most graceful somatic adaptation from a
classic to a comic book movie in
existence but the problem is that on top
of developing new fiends borrowed from A
Tale of Two Cities the film also has to
juggle the themes established in the
Dark Knight and here's where the film
starts to stumble one of the essential
themes of The Dark Knight is truth
versus lies the Dark Knight ends with a
noble lie Thank You Batman
takes responsibility for Harvey Dent's
murders thus denying the fall of Gotham
Savior and upholding the image of him as
an ideal symbol of justice and hope a
thug who showed his true nature when he
betrayed the trust of this great man
herein lies one of the most squandered
opportunities of the film
I believed in Hoxton many incredible
works end with a noble lie in Joseph
Conrad's Heart of Darkness for example
Marlowe lies to curses widow
by telling her that curses last words
were her name saving her from the truth
that he died a deranged psychopath or in
Alan Moore's watchman's the team agrees
to preserve Ozzie man uses lie that
millions were killed by an
extraterrestrial force in order to
maintain peace between the u.s. and the
USSR however both heart of darkness and
Watchmen ends without the truth ever
coming out we're led
to ponder what's more important the
truth or the saving lie the dark night
leaves us with this same ambiguity but
the dark night rises picks up where
these stories left off somatically of
course so finally we get to see what
happens when a noble lie is exposed to
the vulgar truth maybe it's time we all
stop trying to outsmart the truth and
let it have its day does the film live
up to the challenge unfortunately not
really at the beginning of the Dark
Knight Rises we see that the noble lie
has manifested itself in the den tak a
piece of legislation that allows cops
increased power to prosecute organized
crime no city is without crime but this
city is without organized crime because
the dent Act gave law enforcement teeth
in its fight against them up there are
two ways this can be read one we can
read it as a metaphor for the Patriot
Act a law criticized for giving the
government a dangerous amount of power
to fight terrorism considering many
interpret the Joker's radicalism as a
reflection of al-qaeda extremism this
makes sense or to Harvey Dent can be
read as a Christ figure without
resurrection a kind of atheistic
interpretation imagine if Christ never
came back to life but people fabricated
the lie that he did in order to maintain
his divine status and create a religious
institution founded on a lie
based on this reading Christ like den
would be a false idol but one that must
be upheld in order to maintain peace and
hope to build an around this poem i
gossip might even celebrate his legacy
with Harvey Dent Day which I'm sure will
be moved to late December to stimulate
the economy Harvey that day may not be
our oldest public holiday but we're here
tonight because it's one of the most
important considered in this slide but
then that can be likened to the way that
religion has been used to justify
overreaching acts of power like the
Inquisition as juicy as this sound
neither of these extended metaphors
actually pan out because contrary to
what the film wants us to assume there's
no evidence that the product of the lie
is corrupt in fact the death tax seems
to work wonders you and Dan cleaned up
the streets you clean them good for
soon we'll be taken down overdue library
books once Bane reveals the truth that
Harvey Dent is a false idol and the dent
act is built off this lie it leads to
social unrest so is the film trying to
say that bad stuff happens when the
truth is revealed it seems so
considering when Alfred reveals the
truth about Rachel choosing Dent over
Bruce what if before she died and she
wrote a letter saying she chose Harvey
Dent over you it just drives them
further apart and encourages Bruce to go
on a suicide mission but the problem
comes when the film doubles back to the
conclusion at the end of The Dark Knight
because everything is only fixed when
the truth is buried and another lie is
established let it fly out over the
water but yet at the end Wayne lies
about the bats autopilot being broken so
that he can fake his death mr. Proctor
Authority would match career at the
first Wayne thus the narrative of Batman
sacrificing himself for Gotham creates
another image of justice for Gotham to
revere the final lines from A Tale of
Two Cities that Gordon quotes during
Bruce's funeral reflect cartoons
christ-like sacrifice thereby suggesting
that Batman's sacrifice is also
christ-like however as the final shots
of the movie proved Batman did not
sacrifice himself for Gotham but perhaps
it's necessary to believe the lie that
he did just as it was necessary to
believe the lie that Harvey Dent was
Noble to the end after spending nearly
three [ __ ] hours to find out how this
beam of truth will develop we end up
exactly at the same spot as the end of
the Dark Knight establishing the
necessity of a lie to uphold faith in
justice if the theme of the novel I were
to truly develop we might be presented
with a scenario in which the toxic lies
lead you so much corruption that
revealing the lie would be more
beneficial than letting it fester and
destroy Gotham the film attempts to do
this by suggesting that the corruption
of the dent Act leads to Bane social
revolution as evidenced by Gordon's
quote that was needed
[Music]
Bane is supposed to be the outcome of
this toxic lie given Gordon's words it
seems like Bane was meant to function
like the Joker did as a product of
escalation in the Dark Knight we get
super clear exposition that shows the
state of society that leads to the rise
of the Joker oh I don't like tonight
come our chance of winning the Powerball
to run into him Batman has put so many
drug dealers out of business and
inspired so much fear you don't like
what I have to offer you can buy from
someone else
assuming Batman last anyone's Isis that
the mob has been pushed to desperation
leading to the rise of a radically
antithetical form of Batman's brand of
Justice the Joker I thought my jokes
were bad
it seems Gordon was trying to suggest
that when abusive power based on a lie
leads to unsavory political and economic
tension a violent reaction is bound to
happen but once again we have no
evidence of this corruption at the hands
of the dent act or the lie that
justifies it in one scene Catwoman
tricks a man threatening her life by
making him use the cell phone of a
missing congressman and seconds later
the police bump bard in this can be read
as an indication that the dent Act
allows for the monitoring of everyone's
cell phones which would make sense given
the Patriot Act parallel but the problem
is this saves Catwoman's life without
this kind of power Catwoman would be
dead why not show us the negative
consequences of invasive surveillance
the film throws away this opportunity to
comment on how those in power can use a
lie to justify excessive Authority this
brings us to the second theme of the
movie pain is really painful it was very
welcome to try it out first
this theme like truth spends nearly
three hours developing just to bring us
back to where we started at the
beginning Bruce stricken with physical
pain and the pain of losing Rachel
doesn't leave his mansion he overcomes
his pain when he heals his back and
escapes the Lazarus Pit but he
ultimately gives in to pain again when
he decides to stop being Batman bucks
off to Italy and starts living that
bored billionaire lifestyle now I'm
going to bring another literary work in
here to possibly defend the cyclical
nature of these two themes George
Orwell's Animal Farm see an animal farm
Orwell does a very clever thing the term
revolution is given a double
on the one hand it denotes the
revolution when the animals overthrow
their human oppressors but the original
definition of revolution is also given
significance because the novel comes
full circle it revolves at the end the
pigs are just like the humans they
overthrew greedy capitalists so could
the Nolan's be playing with this double
meaning of the word revolution by having
the themes of pain and truth come full
circle in a film about social revolution
maybe or maybe I'm just giving them too
much credit you guys decide the third
major theme in the film is social
inequality but where as A Tale of Two
Cities
aptly displays the decadence and
corruption of the elite that leads to
social unrest The Dark Knight Rises
gives us a vague muddy and almost
nonsensical display of the social
tensions that lead to Bane's false
revolution against the rich not our
money is everybody really as mama
according to Bane Blackgate prison is a
symbol of the dentox oppression Roger
I'm the symbol of oppression Blackgate
is overcrowded men and women sometimes
share cell blocks and criminals under
the dent act don't get parole sure it's
harsh and unjust but it's hardly the
gratuitous cruelty we see in say A Tale
of Two Cities
crowd and slavery it keep the scum
obedient these unfortunate realities
seem to pale in comparison to the
overwhelming success of the dent act
there are 1,000 inmates in Blackgate
prison as a direct result dent Act these
are violent criminals essential cogs in
the organized crime machine especially
considering that the law inability to
fight crime is a central conflict of the
first to fill colonies men doesn't
matter
I never turn to it anyway and even if
Blackgate was wrongfully imprisoned
people how does that translate to
overthrowing the rich black eight is a
clear statement for the Bastille during
the French Revolution and drawing that
analogy out farther the dent act is
meant to be the French lettre de cachet
a kind of warrant issued by the King of
France that detained people without
being burdened by a knowing [ __ ] like
proof or reasonable suspicion the
Bastille became a symbol for the
excesses of the Kings Authority people
could be thrown in jail for practicing
the wrong religion or criticizing the
government or pissing off the wrong
noblemen at the wrong time and when
popular rage finally reached a breaking
point the Bastille was an obvious target
problem is this analogy doesn't really
fit because Blackgate does none of these
things King Louie didn't go around
eradicating the mob and making France
safe with his authority and if the
Gotham police are abusing their
authority like Louie
we're not shown it I also suppose that
this would have complicated the final
showdown scene in which the cops are the
good guys so if the dent act alone
doesn't justify people overthrowing
Gotham's social structures maybe it's
something else the kid in the orphanage
suggests that the economic situation is
making orphans go into the sewers and
join vanes army of course words words
you can applaud
more than you can find up here I guess
but we're given zero indication on how
the dent act or black date are
disenfranchising the poor the only
evidence we see of elite corruption is
when Daggett tries to steal Wayne
Enterprises from Bruce Wayne but that's
the rich screwing over the rich not the
rich screwing over the poor some people
have condemned the Dark Knight Rises as
anti Occupy Wall Street propaganda for
this very reason says no sire it shows a
society that seeks vengeance on the rich
for no other reason than their rich and
sets up kangaroo courts to punish them
no lawyer no witnesses what sort of due
process is this without actually
establishing what these people are
rebelling against it makes it look like
the film is painting occupy activists as
nothing more than easily manipulated
fascistic clowns it's more of an issue
of underdeveloped world building and not
necessarily politically charged
moralizing as I said earlier the Dark
Knight Rises is far from a bad film it
unfortunately falls a bit short but so
goes the tragedy with many trilogies
with so many subplots so many characters
so much ambition and it being so long
it's hard not to see why some of this
got a little mess none of this even
takes me to account that this whole
social unrest scenario is an elaborate
fabrication from the League of Shadows
to destroy Gotham which of course begs
the question why even bother with all
this French Revolution stuff but that's
going to have to be a subject for
another video with a little more
finessing and a tad more attention on
world building this film could have been
a wisecrack e and wet dream and a
fitting conclusion to one of the best
trilogies of our time it's almost that
but it's not thanks for watching
wisecrack be but just because this movie
is a bit of a mess doesn't mean your
legal work has to be see what I did
there
legal zuma is this smart way to take
care of your legal needs and they made
the process of setting up a new business
and more a total breeze LegalZoom
eliminates the guesswork of having to
find an attorney you trust wondering how
much your legal work will cost and
having to take unnecessary trips to a
lawyer's office which always has
terrible parking anyway Legal Zoom works
with a network of independent attorneys
to help you with all sorts of projects
mission of your company wills and trusts
trademarks and patents contracts and
more when we decided to do wisecracks
full-time it was really important that
we set up our business right separating
our personal stuff from the company and
navigating all the intricacies of state
and local laws to be a huge pain illegal
Zoo offers the services and resources to
make sure you get it done right whether
you need to help with your business
family planning or general legal advice
Legal Zoom is there to help wisecrack
fans get 15% off their purchase so head
to legalzoom.com slash wisecracks get
started and save 15% today thanks to
Legal Zoom for sponsoring this video and
hey once again guys thanks so much for
watching we've got lots more planned so
make sure to subscribe so you don't miss
a thing I got to put the finishing
touches on our next Westworld video so
catch you later guys peace
[Music]